functional coding there we go when
people see these words they can
sometimes get a little bit of freight
the hair functionally think how this is
not for me it's very boring not
applicable I don't think so okay I get
that but in this talk I want to try and
give you some real quick wins quick wins
because sometimes you get words like
monads and funk doors and applicatives
thrown around and it can seem very dry
and very academic and not for you well
it really is so this concept of quick
wins I have shamelessly stolen from an
ex Apple engineer called and EEMA to
Shack and the idea is he talks about
lightweight and counters you dip in get
some quick wins and run away for it gets
too hard but the real question is why
bother what you're doing right now works
right your current declarative approach
is fine why change well it turns out
there are a few informal conventions you
know rules to functional programming
what makes good functional code one of
them is we rely very strongly on
immutability we like using constants
everywhere and of course swift enforces
is for us you try and change a constant
you get nothing at all we haven't
compile good functional code avoids
State at all those little properties you
store away settings and so forth it
might start like this but after a few
months if not years what you normally
get a much messy situation so good
functional code avoid states you pass
values into a function change them
inside the function and return new
values you avoid external stuff and of
course this makes a code significantly
easier to test you know that function a
will always return 1 2 3 4 the same
values every single time regardless of
any properties you might be using good
functional code is composable you write
small functions that do wander be to
things then combine together to make
bigger functions like Lego bricks but
most importantly good functional code
allows us to express our intent clearly
it clarifies our intent use your quote
stolen from xavier soto
from twitch he says it allows us to
express what we want to achieve rather
than how it's implemented smart man now
enough intro let's get to the code
something is map map works great on
collections and optionals and we're
starting easy collections ok where does
it transform stuff values come in get
transformed by a closure rights and
emitted as transformed values example 1
2 3 4 map can double that to be 2 4 6 8
nice and easy
play some English words camping parking
in weekend we can say hey map make that
French as Dumas said English is just
French badly pronounced map could even
try and make olympic marseille it's a
good football team but probably not now
as an example imagine a function to
accept an array of names John Paul
George and Ringo and your list function
to transform those names into the links
of those names nice and simple we know
that John has 4 Paul has 4 George has 6
Ringo has 5 array of strings in int
array of counts back you're doing that
declaratively you would say length of
string string array going in return int
array make a new empty int array loop
over the strings add my count to the
intr a and the loop and return the
results that is your declarative
function so imperative throughout that
functionally you would say step 1 get
rid of all that code step 2
you'd write strings dot map dollar 0 so
count step 3
well there is no step 3 that's all your
code now and the best bit is the
function signature hasn't changed all
the code that calls this function can be
as nasty as it is right now
this code can be improved so you can go
ahead and chisel away at your bad code
base and improve it as you go now if you
don't use close as much
dollar 0 just means the element being
passed in so John then Paul then George
then Ringo now this code is shorter of
course this code shorter but that's not
the real win here ok this code is in
to build that variable integer array
gone but it also clarifies what we're
trying to do our intent clear when you
call map on a sequence like I did there
it must transform all the items in there
you can't bail out part way through for
laughs
internally to Swift it looks a bit like
this a simplified it's like this is map
internally to Swift and standard library
map transform some generic thing or turn
the generic array of T create a new
empty array of T loops over the items
itself and then transforms your item
puts into the return value then ends a
loop returns turn value and returns the
function that's exactly the same code
you would have written except now it's
Swift's problem now it's Ben's problem
for Apple they like that work better
which means they can optimize that over
time to be better and faster and you
don't care your code just improves you
can map all sorts of things here's an
integer array 108 85 we could say map
that into strings your score was dollar
0 your score 100 score 80 or 85 we could
have a masked Rama crammed come on waste
applause my friend Shay thank you thank
you we can say I want to map that to be
uppercase and I'll just return those
things upper case we could say his array
of doubles 2 4 9 and 16 we could pass
that straight to the square root
function and get back to 3/4 map all
sorts of things and actually earlier
Daniel Steinberg gave me a lovely
analogy for how map works similar to you
I've used in UIKit we're very
comfortable the idea of saying here's a
view I already said animate with a 5
second duration from where you are down
to the bottom right corner and it will
do so we haven't got to tell it exactly
where to be in every frame of the
animation we just say the start point
and the end point the transformation and
let you I kids sorts it out very same as
a map that is map move on flat map in a
smaller type compact map is being
renamed because of course you know Swift
or are in Swift for one which is command
next code and I've put three years ago
it's now compact map this precise you
just I'm talking about but it's very
similar to map please already map and
your brain you think you've more as a
transformation happening
of course there is the second part the
flattered / compact part it does
something really cool after the map
transformation completes it will unwrap
your optionals then throw away any Nils
for you and nil occurs in all sorts of
places and Swift
so if loves nil expel initializers or
try question mark or conditional
typecast and so forth all of these when
they fail return nil
so when you say create integer from this
string number 5a will actually be an
optional integer because you may have
said not as your number and of course
the French don't you anyway you get nil
back for that so nil brilliant good food
to flatmap let's see that the flat map
thinks of that we can say here's an
array of 1 5 fish deer flat map please
put that through the initially and what
get back is this numbers array will be
an int array not optionality here
whatsoever it's a real int array it'll
work out like this we have 1 5 fish it
goes through the International Iser
which is available it comes back with
optional one optional 5 Neil the
flattening there compacting part kicks
off unwraps the optional tosses away the
nails out comes one five beautiful so
anywhere you have failed but initialized
you should be thinking Oh flat map for
example got an array of strings that
might be URLs might not be let's find
out try and make your ELLs out of them
for lucky there we go if it fails blob
tosses my way an array of UI views some
of which might be UI image use great
just do a conditional typecast the ones
you get back our image juice you can
even just do this there's no
transformation happening here
you're just saying please give me your
lovely compacting behavior please under
optionals and toss away the nails that's
flat map now both of these things work
on optionals - you can do an optional
map and an optional flat map and they
work in slightly different ways they can
option of being a box map will open the
box
it'll extract the Condit's of a box
sabatello and of course transform out
into vast amounts of money right now for
the rioters and then it will put that
thing back in the box so it rewrap sit
back in and optionally
get an optional you end up with an
optional so in code
if you imagine a method like this get
user ID give an ID number 97 if it
exists you get a string back if it
doesn't get nil back that's an optional
string return value we can pass that
thing through map and if name is Bill
nothing happens you get back nil
immediately but if name is not nil
you'll get high user name high
jean-pierre and then you can say go
ahead and print the greeting little
coalescing unknown user now it's the
same thing declaratively you might say
the same court start then an empty
constant do a quick unwrap put it into
the variable then to have an else block
lucky there we go unknown user and the
else and then pronoun greetings crazy
there we go now easy enough but what if
what in the box isn't what you thought
you open the box out comes your prize
transform to big cash but this time it
is optional what happens then
let's find out so here we have an
optional string containing 5 we say okay
let's try and map that to an integer
what type is result spoiler it is not an
integer it's not even an optional
integer what you've got here is the
lesser known and completely never wanted
optional optional integer which really
screws with your head no one wants to
see these things now when we said map
what we meant to say really was flat map
and now result will be a regular
optional int that we feel more
comfortable with you see when you call
map or an optional and your
transformation closure returns an
optional map just puts them together you
get an optional optional flat map is
able to say it's the same container
let's join them together it can turn
that into a single optional either the
whole thing is there or the whole thing
is not there but your transformation
closure returns an optional use flat map
do you want filter you like coffee and
France don't you still Turing filtering
is way
can say here's a condition I want to
check pass this collection or sequence
through this filter and see what comes
out for example I have an array of red
and blue boxes I have a filter looking
for blue boxes I can now say run it
through the Reds are thrown away
balloons come back
that's my return value so time for some
examples and that's of course play to
the crowd a little bit let good wine
equals Wyandotte filter origins France
let band equals player stop filter has a
prefix Kevin the band Hittle called
Kevin from the thing great you can tell
us whatever you like let's filter these
numbers based on where they are odd or
not using modulus and there's so many
more swift pack these lovely functional
functions you can call on I love the
first method this will find the first
score over 85 like that if you've got a
ray of numbers 9 5 3 5 and your cat Hoff
and they appear
trivial you can put it through map make
an array of tuples
so it'll produce an array like this nine
one five one two three one five one then
swift for there's a new dictionary
initializer it will treat that array of
tuples as key value pairs so keys one
values one keys three values one and so
forth
it's called unique and keys with and
when it finds a collision in the keys I
get will four five and five
it'll add the one on the one together so
wrote result will be nine appears once
five appears twice three appears once
it's trivial to do there's a classic one
you'll see in so many talks how to add
an array of numbers using reduce and
plus it's shown so many time because
it's beautiful it shows you how swift
just totally blurs the lines doing
functions and methods and operators and
closures one big thing of beautifulness
and swift you can even take it's ready
for more French you can even take
non-functional things you know already
and apply them isn't of rain we weigh
the answer you can say it's like the
saying we you know this there's a
contains method arrays you know this and
as a stream contains we can say in
marathon said we look at the aim we wait
put the two together you can now say
here's my array of what we wear beyond
suit here's my string and then say yes
doc contains wear replied or contains do
any of those words appear in that string
done now there are some challenges to
switching to a more functional approach
of course there are first up muscle
memory we sit down at your desk great to
face the same problems we face before
you naturally reach the same solutions
you used before switching to map or flat
map or reduce or whatever you want to do
is a mental jump but it's worth it
second up some folks will tell you Swift
is not a functional language or a true
functional language and the you know
semantics it's functional it's protocol
oriented it's the clarity of its
object-oriented it's good but one of the
biggest ones is that state is
comfortable we like storing things in
properties right and then referring to
them later on so getting away from that
get into what you might call a pure
function where you only refer to the
values inside the function takes ER work
and that's okay
so let's wrap up first up I hope you
learn soon you I hope you impressed by
my French suck it up you weren't you
scared
I did try and keep it as simple as
possible quite as applicable as possible
and thirdly I hope that tomorrow you can
go back to your desk and apply what
you've learned she just learned
functional program look at happy she is
right that could be you merci beaucoup
[Applause]